[MUSIC PLAYING]
NICK MIHAILOVSKI:
How many people
here have used Google Sheets?
All right.
How many people here have
used Google Data Studio?
All right.
So if you haven't
seen Data Studio,
we'll be highlighting it today.
My name is Nick.
Product manager for
Google Data Studio.
I'm here with Dan, product
manager on Google Sheets.
We have some wonderful partners.
One from Analytics Pros, one
from Whirlpool, and we'll
be taking you through
different products.
We'll be giving you
a quick overview
on where we would see
some of the challenges
that we've heard
from our customers,
and how we're actually solving
them with Sheets and Data
Studio.
We have some great
partner success
stories about how they've been
able to leverage our solutions.
And then we'll wrap up and
answer any of the questions
that you guys have.
So let's jump in it.
So we're in the midst of
an amazing transformation
of people going from
traditional to digital media.
How many of you people
have phones in your pockets
right now?
How many people own
more than one phone?
Own two phones?
How many people own five phones?
Right.
Some of these people.
There's a lot of phones, right?
Now imagine all those
applications on your phones.
Each of those applications
actually collecting data.
Now imagine all the
applications you
have across your other
computers and your tablets.
There's a lot of
data being generated.
Now imagine all the devices
and all of the different
like the Internet of Things.
All of your home devices
that are sending data.
In fact, the amount
of data is exploding.
Here's a great chart we
got from Cisco showing
the exponential growth of data.
And what's interesting about
it is that it's not just data,
the amount of data is growing,
but the number of data sources
is growing too.
So it presents a big challenge
of how do you manage this data.
Or strategically, how
can you actually take
advantage of this data?
Or rather, if your competitors
take advantage of this data
faster than you where
does that leave you
in a competitive landscape?
So when we started
talking to our customers
about how did they
actually work with data,
it turns out they all go
through a common workflow.
Everybody needs to be
able to collect data,
they need to be
able to prepare it,
they need to be able
to do some analysis,
answer some business questions.
They need to then report
those analyses to stakeholders
and share them.
But what we found
is that limitations
in any of these stages causes
people to use different tools.
And it turns out people
use many different tools
to go through this.
And what we find
that it's actually
because so many people
use different tools,
it becomes expensive
and difficult to manage.
Now imagine it like you
have your boss asking you
for some performance numbers.
How well did you perform
in the last quarter?
Well, how would you go about it?
You'd go probably
try to get some data,
maybe across some
different sheets,
then you're probably working
to put it all together,
answer some basic questions
about what your growth was.
Putting that into
some presentations,
and then sharing
them around by email.
Now what happens if your boss
now asks you for new numbers
or asks what if you
could tweak something?
You have to go through the
whole process all over again,
taking a ton of time.
Now what happens if
the boss actually says,
hey, I'd like to see
this on a daily basis.
Think about how
much work that is.
It is actually complex,
and we probably
do go through this
quite frequently.
And the issue with that
is that what we find then
is that there's very
limited number of people
within an organization
who actually have the time
to actually go through that.
And that leads to
these analytics silos
where a few people who
have access to this data
have the skill set and time to
be able to work with the data
and make actual
proper decisions.
And so this is really
the business challenge
of how do we actually
empower all users
within an organization
to make better decisions.
So with that, we have two
amazing products from Google--
Google Sheets, Data Studio.
Our vision with these products
here is to make it really easy.
Have a single suite
of products that
makes it easy to go
between and work with data.
We're trying to make
it really efficient
to make you more productive.
And so ease of use and
usability is a big key factor
of how we build our products.
And we also want to make
them very affordable.
As you know, Sheets
is part of G Suite.
With Data Studio,
it's completely free.
We just announced that
We just launched it
to over 180 countries,
so we really want everybody
to take advantage of it.
So with that, let's just
jump into a Sheets overview.
I'd like to introduce Dan.
DAN GUNDRUM: Thank you, Nick.
As Nick mentioned,
my name is Dan.
I'm a product manager on
the Google Sheets' team.
And it looked like from
the hands that a lot of you
already use Sheets.
So that's awesome and great.
I'm really excited.
Hopefully, in this section,
since it is an overview,
hopefully I'll still be teaching
you some tips and tricks
that you might not even
know about Sheets today.
But before we get
into that, I just
wanted to take a quick look.
If we can switch back
to the slides actually,
not the demo yet.
I just see that.
Great.
Perfect.
We actually take a
quick look back to 2006.
This is what Sheets looked like.
If you look closely
at the screen,
you'll probably see that there
weren't a lot of features.
It was actually still a
beta product at the time.
It was not an enterprise
grade solution in 2006.
However, it was in the cloud.
Even back in 2006,
we were already,
the data was already
being stored in the cloud.
Now fast forward
to today, and we
have added a lot to sheets
over the past few years.
And I'll go through
some of the features,
but it really is a supercharged
and powerful productivity tool.
Let's go through
some of the features.
These are just a
few of the things
that we added over
the past few years.
For example, scale.
Back in 2006, you only could
handle like 100 cells of data.
Now, we scale to millions and
millions of cells of data.
We also have every
function you need in order
to perform analysis.
I listed just a few up
there on the screen,
but there are
hundreds and hundreds.
And additionally, there
are some really interesting
unique functions that
are only found in Sheets,
and I'll get to those
a little bit later.
There's also things
like publishing,
macros, the ability to
write custom functions,
advance charting.
The list goes on.
Now, I'd actually call
a lot of these things
actually table stake features.
A lot of the things that
a lot of you in the room
would probably expect out of an
enterprise grade productivity
solution.
However, Sheets actually
has quite a few industry
leading unique features in
order to do data analysis
and help you create these
dashboards and reports as well.
I'll jump through a few of them.
First of all, as I
was hinting to before,
real time collaboration.
Even back in 2006, Sheets
was born on the web.
We get this really nice.
We're all in the cloud.
You can collaborate in real
time with other people.
You're working on the same file.
There's no need to send
attachments back and forth
or use email.
Regardless of the device
you're working on as well,
you're all just working
on the same thing.
Because we're in the cloud
and because there's real time
collaboration, it makes working
together much more efficient.
However, we know as well
that you're not always
collaborating.
Sometimes you're doing the
bulk of your work by yourself.
Sheets also has some really
interesting and unique features
for that as well.
For example, add-ons.
Add-ons if you're not familiar
are secure third-party features
that run inside of Sheets that
can extend its functionality.
They can do things
like automate workflows
to make your business
run more efficiently.
Or you can pull in data
from other sources.
In the screenshot, you
actually see on the left
an add-on called
Supermetrics that
can pull from Facebook and
Twitter and Google Analytics
and a variety of sources.
And because it's the cloud,
it always stays up to date.
As data changes, the data in the
spreadsheet will also update.
There's hundreds of add-ons
already in the add-on store.
However, if your company uses
a system or a service that
isn't already available
through add-ons,
you can also create
an add-on yourself.
It's extensible and
open to everyone.
And one of the best
parts is that it's
really easy to get started.
You don't need to learn a
special programming language.
You do need to know a
little bit of coding,
but it's not special.
It's just JavaScript.
It's something if you've dabbled
in web programming before
or know some web basics, you
could get started basically
immediately.
You could start
hooking it up today.
So that's add-ons.
We also have some
unique formulas
to bring in data as well.
As shown on the left,
the import data function.
This is a unique
Sheets function that
pulls in data from websites.
And again, like other
services on the cloud,
it stays up to date.
So as the data updates
on the website, the data
in the spreadsheet
also automatically
updates seamlessly,
efficiently, quickly.
If you're working
with financial data,
we have the Google
Finance function.
That also updates regularly.
There's a whole
class of functions,
and I'll show one a little
bit more later as well.
There's a whole class of
functions in this bucket that
can pull data from other
sources in your sheet
and keep it up to date.
And then if you want to analyze
the data or see the trends,
we have other functions like
the Sparkline function, which
can put a miniature
in-cell cell chart of data,
so you can see the direction,
see trends, see how it's going.
So you've either brought now
your data in through an add-on,
you've imported it, you've used
one of these unique functions.
It's now time to
analyze it, prepare it,
going through the steps that
Nick was mentioning earlier.
And that's where a feature
called Explore comes in.
Over the last year
in Sheets, we added
a feature called Explore that
brings machine intelligence
into the product.
So what do I mean by
machine intelligence?
I'm basically referring to
Google's smart algorithms that
extract trends and find
insights in your data
for you to help you out.
For example, Explore
will suggest charts
that help make sense of the
data you just pulled in.
Or they'll show you little
key snippets and insights
to help extract outliers
or interesting information.
Or just recently announced
a few months ago,
you can just ask Explore a
question in plain English.
You don't have to write
a formula or a function
or do code.
Just ask.
We really think this makes data
analysis much easier, simpler,
and faster.
This brings analysis to all
users inside of a company.
It's directly in a spreadsheet.
This is what people, as
you all were saying before,
you're all using spreadsheets.
And so this is bringing
sophisticated analysis directly
to you in the place
you're already using.
There's no other
spreadsheet tool
that has features like this.
There are products.
You might have to use separate
complex, expensive tools
to get features like this.
But we include it all
together in G Suite.
So with that, now we'll
switch over to the computer.
I'll give you a quick live demo.
I've mentioned a lot, so
I'll basically now show you
everything I was mentioning.
We'll start out with
one of the formulas.
Like I said, there's a whole
class of import formulas.
I'll start with--
as I type in, we'll
see auto complete
of some of them.
I'm going to choose the
import range function.
This allows me to import data
from another spreadsheet.
For example, if information
was shared with you
in another spreadsheet,
you can pull it in.
So I'll just switch over to
this other tab, grab the URL.
This is the data I want to pull.
I'll put that in there.
And then use just specify
the sheet name as well.
So it's on Sheet 1.
And it'll come in
in just a second.
Perfect.
So now the data that was
in the other spreadsheet
is now pulled into
this spreadsheet.
And as the data in the
other spreadsheet changes,
this one also stays up to
sync, because it's a formula.
It's linked.
I could have just
copied and pasted,
but then it wouldn't
have stayed up to date.
So this keeps the data
fresh and up to date
from another source
in a spreadsheet.
All right.
So now the data is in.
Let's see what Google
can help me with.
I could go through
and do an analysis.
But as I was mentioning
before, in the bottom corner,
we have Explore.
Let me just open that up and see
what it tells me that I can do.
First of all, one of
the first things I see
is that it's suggesting some
formatting suggestions to me.
This will make it
easier to read.
So let me just click that
button, and in one click,
I'm able to more easily read
the data in this spreadsheet.
It automatically
found the header row.
And it automatically found
the bounds of the table.
It automatically cut
it off, so I didn't
have to select the data even.
Explore just knew
where to go with that.
All right.
So now I have some formatting.
Now I want to
start to understand
this data little better.
Make sense of it.
Let's ask Sheets questions.
Like I said before, you
don't need to write formulas
in order to do analysis.
You see some examples here
that can get you started.
I'll just type in
a few of my own.
For example, let's
just actually type,
what's the average
profit margin?
And as you see,
autocomplete can help
me make sure I'm not
making typos and mistakes
and things like that.
Makes that a little
faster to enter.
And right there, without having
to write a formula or anything,
I see that the average profit
margin in this sales data
is about 22%.
So I just did that
really quickly.
I didn't need to know any
special spreadsheet formulas.
If I'm not an
expert or anything,
I was able to do
that seamlessly.
Let's try something a
little bit harder though.
Like that was an average.
Maybe most of you in this room,
if you're familiar with Sheets,
know an average.
Let me ask something like
what was the top selling
item on Black Friday?
They were talking about Black
Friday earlier in the keynote,
so I thought that
was interesting.
And right there, I
press Enter, and I
get the answer returned
to me is a jacket.
We sold 20 of them on Black
Friday in my small business.
Now, let me see, let me
show you this formula.
That's what you would
have had to have known
in order to get that data
from this spreadsheet.
And if you also notice in
our little answer here,
we saw that Black Friday
was November 25 of 2016.
I didn't have to go to Google.
I didn't have to look this up.
I just asked Sheets, and
using Google's knowledge,
we just knew that date.
We found that in
the spreadsheet,
and we provided
the answer to you.
It was seamless,
easy, efficient,
and I did it in
basically five seconds.
Not having to
write that formula,
probably would have taken
me quite a bit of time
even as a Sheets expert.
All right.
So now I'm starting to
understand this data little bit
better.
I'll show you some of the
other things Explore offers.
First of all, I'll just
pull in some charts.
For example, I'm
seeing that Explore's
recommending this chart that has
an interesting pattern to it.
The cost of the
goods versus profit.
And I can just simply
drag that in if I
wanted to start developing a
dashboard or a report directly
in Sheets.
And it's showing this nice
trend as the costs go up,
my profit goes up as well.
The dollar amounts.
And you can see some
of the other insights
and a bunch of other charts.
For example, these are the
types of items I'm selling.
I can pull that in as well.
And I can continue
to go down as well.
For example, the manufacturers.
Explore is finding a lot
of these insights for me.
And so I'm just inserted
several different charts
using different data
ranges in my data,
and I just drag them in.
Explore found these
interesting things,
and I've been basically setting
up this dashboard or report
in a matter of seconds.
All right.
So now we can switch
back to the slides.
Basically, to summarize, I just
went through the first half
of this flow.
I collected data from
another spreadsheet.
I started analyzing
and preparing it.
I could have inserted
some formulas.
I started inserting some
charts and stuff like that.
Nick will come up
in a few seconds
and also take you through
the second half of this
of how Data Studio, you
can start using this data
that we used in Sheets, we
started analyzing a little bit
more, and then generate
some of these reports
and share them out.
That was a quick, like 10 to
15 minute overview of Sheets.
However, if you do want
more information on Sheets,
we have a whole other session
later today at 4:00 PM.
Check that out.
We're going to go even
deeper into Sheets.
It's going to be about
an hour long session.
Highly recommend that.
And if there's not enough
time for questions at the end,
we also have demo
booths and Q&A sections
that's in Moscone Center.
That's running all
week, so we can
answer any questions you have
about Data Studio and Sheets.
And with that, I'll
hand it off back to Nick
who will go over Data Studio.
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: There it is.
Thanks a lot, Dan.
So let's talk a little
bit about Data Studio.
Dan just talked you through
about how we can collect data,
how we can prepare,
how we can analyze it.
Let's talk about how we can
actually do some reporting
and dashboarding on it.
How we can collaborate
with our peers.
So for people who haven't
known, Google Data Studio
is actually a
relatively new product.
We launched less
than a year ago.
May last year.
Since our launch, we made
the product 100% free.
And just yesterday, we announced
our global availability,
so now the product's
available in 180 countries.
So everybody can
use it right away.
Go ahead and use it.
I'll be doing a demo.
You can follow along
in the demo as well.
We also just launched a
new data import feature
where you can import
data for two gigabytes
completely for
free for everybody.
We actually store the data
on Google Cloud Storage,
so it's a really nice
feature that we just added.
Now, I really want
to get into a demo.
But before that, I
want to highlight
some of our unique capabilities
of the product in case
you don't know them.
The core aspect of
Data Studio is really
to communicate information.
And to do that, we want to
make you a hero when you use
our tools, and we really
strived hard to make
it easy to build
beautiful reports.
We have a very
easy WYSIWYG editor
to help build out these reports.
Tons of styles.
Tons of charting.
We can make them
completely interactive
so consumers or viewers
of these reports
can actually explore
them themselves.
And you can actually make
these multiple pages.
You can actually curate
a story around your data.
Getting data into the
product is really easy.
We've built many
different connectors
to popular Google products.
We also have connectors
to on premise data,
including MySQL and Postgres.
And again, we just launched
our CSV import for two gigs
where you can import
data directly to Google
and start visualizing your data.
Once you get your
data into the product,
we also have some ad
hoc transformations
that we allow you to do.
You can do quick aggregations
across your data.
I'll show you some
of how that works.
You can do ad hoc groupings
and also calculations.
So it becomes quite
powerful as a BI solution.
And finally, the last
part is we've actually
really love how G Suite,
how simple it is to share.
And so we've brought that
sharing technology to your data
through Data Studio.
And so with Google
Data Studio, you
can share your reports
with individual users,
you can share them
with Google Groups,
you can make them
completely public.
All these files actually
show up on Google Drive
as a first class experience.
And you can collaborate in real
time, which is really cool.
And I'll show you a
demo how to do that.
So enough talking.
Let me jump right into the demo.
If we can go over to
the computer, please.
Cool.
So let's just jump right in.
I'm going to go to
datastudio.google.com.
If you guys have a computer,
you can jump along as well.
So here's all the
reports I have access to.
I'm going to go ahead
and create a new report.
I'll go ahead and click
the plus button here.
And the first thing I need to do
is to create a new data source.
So I'll click Create
a New Data Source.
Now, here's all the
different connectors
that we offer, again, to
a lot of Google products,
but we're adding a lot
of connectors as well.
For this demo, I'm going to
connect to Google Sheets.
And what I'm going to do is
connect to that Black Friday
report.
Whoops.
Cool.
And I'll connect to the
first and connect it.
OK.
So what we've quickly done is
we've connected to the sheet.
We actually pool all
the different columns
as what we call a
field, and then we
associate that with some
conjectural information.
For example, these types.
We've automatically inferred
what the data is here,
and then we've given some types
to some of these other columns.
So if some of these here,
for example, the unit price
is a number.
I can go ahead
and model this out
so that way it's a currency.
So let me put that in
to price is currency.
Margin here.
Make that currency as well.
Cost of goods.
We can put that
also as a currency.
And you can see that we've
had some aggregations
here happen out of the box.
So for example, unit price
will be summing by default,
and profit margin will
be summing as well.
So I'll use that.
I'll go ahead and add
this to my report.
And now we're back into
the WYSIWYG editor.
So to start visualizing
data, all I need to do
is come in here to this
tool panel at the top.
I'll use a bar chart.
I'll select it, and I'll
just draw it right here
on the canvas.
And just like that
we're visualizing data.
It was that simple.
It was less than a minute.
Less than two minutes.
And what we're doing
here is we're showing
the metric here, serial number.
What we can do is now
go into our unit price
or let's say our profit margin.
That was really interesting.
And what we'll do is
we're aggregating.
We're pulling out all
the different pants
and we're summing
what the margin was
across all the different pants.
And we're summarizing that
here right in this chart.
So this is really nice.
I can quickly come in here
and start visualizing data.
Everything here is live data.
So if I Control C,
Control V, I'll actually
make a copy of this, and I
could bring it down right here.
So here we're looking at the
profit margin at the top.
I could actually
change my metric
to look at the
number of units sold.
We could see, of
course, the number pants
corresponds to the number
of units sold as well.
If I looked at unit
price, we could
see the jackets are
a lot more expensive.
It has the highest
cost whereas the pants
have a much lower cost.
So again, we've just
provided a very simple way
of allowing people to
start exploring visually
how the data works.
OK.
So let me just go
here to unit price.
The other thing we could
do with this report
is we can actually add a
nice little title on here.
So let's just say, let's just
make this a little bit bigger.
32.
Black Friday Sales.
And let's make this interactive.
So let's add a little
filter control on here.
So we can go ahead and
add filter control.
And with the filter
control, there's
a bunch of different
things we can do.
For this one, let's just
make this expandable.
And on the data, instead
of using the item
let's use the manufacturer.
Cool.
So now if I go into View
mode, what you'll notice
is that everything
here is interactive.
And when I click on
the manufacturer,
I can see all the
different manufacturers
and I could actually
now interactively
start exploring through
this curated experience
I just built. Everything
is super easy to use.
It's all drag and drop.
It's all web based.
Super easy.
So I want to make this report
look a little bit prettier.
But I don't have a lot of
time, so what I'm going to do
is I want to collaborate
with my colleague, Dave.
So the first thing I want
to do is share this report.
So as I mentioned, we've
integrated directly with Drive
here.
So what I'll do
here is add Dave.
And hopefully if
the internet works,
I can send him an
invite request.
So what that did is it actually
sent an email over to Dave
who's sitting in the audience.
It should come in his inbox,
and it should be a link.
And so Dave, if you
can click the link.
Hopefully, you got it.
Did you get it?
All right.
He got it.
Here he is.
There he is.
There's Dave.
So Dave's now into this
collaborative report.
And if I go now into Edit mode,
I can actually see Dave here
in the report.
So Dave, why don't you
go ahead and style this.
Maybe I'll.
So here, look.
Hands free.
I'm building a report,
and what we've done here
is integrate with real
time collaboration.
And the nice aspect
of this is next time
when you're in a
meeting, and you're
working with your
boss has a question
or you want to
update your slides,
you can now actually
update these reports
live in real time, and
it's all live data.
So here, Dave,
maybe let's change
a dimension from manufacturer
to something else in the drop
down.
Cool.
So now it's on Item.
Now, if I go into
View mode, notice
how everything is wired up.
And now it's all dynamic,
and I can actually
do on the fly filtering, what
Jay just updated in real time.
So again, super easy feature.
Super powerful feature.
And very easy to start
building these interactive
experiences that you can share.
We know starting
with a blank report
is very difficult
for many people.
So we've built a bunch
of custom templates,
and we're adding a
lot of work to help
make it easy get started.
What I'm going to do is
show you a few of them
just to show you what's
possible that you can create.
So this one was a report we
created for a health care
company.
We branded it.
We added a logo.
We styled it blue, because
health care is blue.
And you can notice
how pretty it is.
Here we have showing off
some of the visualizations,
showing what you can do in terms
of customizing this experience.
And again, everything
here is interactive.
If I change it to the last
10 days, then hit Apply.
Notice how everything
is updating here
live in real time.
So again, powerful tool to
make these beautiful reports.
Here's another one that we did.
We themed this one black.
If you are running
advertising, you
can use this report to
look at your own data.
And there's a bunch
of other templates.
Cool.
So that's a quick
overview of Data Studio.
Just the tip of the iceberg.
Definitely invite you to
go and try it out yourself.
As you saw how easy it was
for me to create a report,
should be easy for you to
create a report as well.
If we could jump
back to the slides.
So the big thing here that we
really want you to take away
is that we have a lot
of powerful tools.
But for you guys, we really
want to make them easy
so you can be more
productive, and we're
offerings these tools to you
at a very competitive price
point, which is free.
And through G Suite as
well if your company
is buying it as well.
So definitely, next
time you're thinking
about how do I work with
data, definitely look
at the solutions
that are available
and consider Sheets and Data
Studio for your next project.
So I've just talked
a lot about why
we think our tools are great.
But what's even better is to
have our partners come on stage
and talk about how they are
able to actually use them
within their own business.
So I'd like to introduce
Jeremy up stage
to talk about how he's
using it at Analytics Pros.
JEREMY ECHOLS: Cool.
So I'm Jeremy Echols.
I'm the manager of analytics,
growth, and development
at Analytics Pros.
And we're a digital
analytics consultancy.
And as such, we
get the privilege
of working with a lot
of really great clients
and a lot of really
great companies.
And at the end of the day,
what we're seeking to do
is actually solving
real problems
that they're running into
day to day with their data.
One example of that we're
going to walk through here
is with Food Lion.
And Food Lion's a grocery store
chain within the southeast
United States.
And with that, as we've
talked about today with data,
we run into lots of issues
of lots of individuals
are working with data.
There's lots of systems
that that data is housed in,
and that creates a
lot of complications.
And then with Food
Lion, we actually
run into even bigger
complications in the fact
that we're not just dealing
with individuals and systems,
but we're also dealing with
lots of different agencies,
organizations, and vendors.
And so I want to talk
through how we've actually
sought to simplify a lot of that
using the solutions of Google
Sheets as well as Data Studio.
So as we started
working with Food Lion,
there were a few
things that we ran
into that we knew we
had areas of disconnect
in how we worked
with their data.
The first area is
with social data.
With social data,
with Food Lion,
like many different
companies, they're
on many different
social platforms.
And so that was the
first thing that we had.
We had different data sets,
different user interfaces
for their social data.
On top of that, they used
different organizations
and different vendors
for their CPC campaigns
as well as on top of that for
their social communication
in general.
The next area that
I'll talk about
is going to be in-store
coupon activity.
This is a third party
vendor that they
use for customers
that need to activate
coupons for their
loyalty card as well
as redeem them in-store.
And all of that data is actually
hosted in that third party
vendor system with
limited access.
And then finally, I'm going
to talk about connecting
online to in-store behavior.
And what that really is that
Food Lion has a website that
doesn't actually sell anything.
And so what really matters
at the end of the day
are are their customers
actually going to in-store
and how does the website
activity influence that.
So we needed to join data
from multiple systems.
So touching the first
one of social data.
Really what we sought
to do here was actually
moving all of their data
from multiple systems
into one system.
So you see here that
their primary areas
are looking at Facebook,
Twitter, and Pinterest.
And so with that there's a
lot of different datasets
and a lot of
different interfaces
that we're working with.
And so we were able to utilize
the previously mentioned
add-on Supermetrics in order
to take the powerful feature
that Sheets has and plug-in an
add-on to connect to the APIs
for Facebook, the APIs for
Twitter, as well as Pinterest.
And from that we were able to
actually put all of that data
into an automatically updated
sheet within Google Sheets
to have all raw
data into one place.
So now all of
these teams weren't
having to actually go
get the original data
from each of those interfaces.
And then beyond that we then
were able to clean it up,
put it into a schema
that Data Studio
could have read as a
data source in order
to have beautiful visual
reports that actually matched
the branding for
Food Lion instead
of just using the interface
of, say, Facebook Insights.
And so how we were
able to do that is we
were able to move
just from having
the sheets and the raw
data, which is super helpful
to have in one place,
but move from that
by having the powerful
features of the formulas
that exist inside of Sheets.
And so as you see
there on the left,
we had a very complex formula
that would automatically
update based on what day
it was to always look back
into a clean dataset looking
at last month's social data.
And from this, we
were able to combine
a lot of datasets
that actually weren't
possible within the
Facebook Insights interface.
And so here we have the example
of how we were able to show
them the Facebook post
engagement-- likes, comments,
and shares that
were taking place--
broken out by day of week
as well as by post type.
And so what this allowed was
actually a much faster way
to get insights for their data
that actually led to action.
They were able to
take that information,
know what day of week
their audience was
active on Facebook, as
well as what type of posts
would actually get the
most amount of response.
The next area is going to be the
in-store coupon activity area.
So the way that this works
since this was a third party
vendor working with their data
and just sending it back out
because there was limited
access to that raw data,
they were actually just emailing
a spreadsheet file every month
to the main point of
contact at Food Lion.
And then from that
throughout the month
as people needed
access to that data
for coupon activations
and redemptions,
they were actually
just emailing it
to the team
throughout the month.
This creates a
lot of complexity,
and a lot of problems that
can come about from this.
Because by the end of
the month, you might even
have adjustments that
were made to the file
and people are looking
at different sets of data
as a result. So what
we were able to do
was to work with that
vendor along with Food Lion
and use Google Sheets
as a central point.
So no longer we're
having the inefficiencies
of emailing files
around in order
to get that type of
information collaboratively.
And then from there,
we were actually
able to take them
from people having
different versions
of a spreadsheet file
that had been emailed
to them, and actually
put it into Data
Studio in order to have
now interactive reports.
Instead of just having
a flat spreadsheet that
has multiple different
forms throughout the month,
we were actually
able to show this.
And here's the example we used
of a scatterplot inside of Data
Studio in order to show
the relationship of coupon
redemptions compared
to coupon activations.
So a shopper puts a coupon
onto their loyalty card,
and does it actually result
for that product category,
does it result in an
in-store purchase?
Because at the end of the
day, what they need to know
is what type of
product categories
are actually driving
users to not just be
interested in having the
coupon on their card,
but actually
redeeming it in-store
and causing the
in-store store behavior.
And then the third area is
connecting online to in-store.
So the way that we
did this when we first
started working
with Food Lion, we
created a schema within their
dataset for Google Analytics
that whenever a
user logs in online,
we actually collected
that user's MVP loyalty
identification number.
And we put that into
a custom dimension
into Google Analytics.
And what that allowed was for
us to actually, every time we
needed to extract that data to
know what users were logged in
and were active on
Food Lion's website,
we were able to export that
out to Sheets for Food Lion's
business intelligence
team to work with,
and to know what type of
data they were working with,
and what type of users they had.
And so what Food Lion's
business intelligence team
was able to do in the
collaborative setting
like Google Sheets is they
were able to actually take
all of those user IDs
to know who they were
and how many sessions
each of those users had.
And then from there,
actually understand
what categories do
those users fall into.
And they could
compare and contrast
all of the data that was coming
in from their transaction
database on the back end
compared to their Google
Analytics interface.
And so with that,
they were able to see
users that are existing
to the website,
meaning they've actually been
logged in, and been using
the website.
Users that were new to
the website that had just
started using it this month.
As well as users who
were not actually
active on the website at all.
And immediately this
caused an impact inside
of Food Lion's
ecosystem of data to be
able to say users who
were actually engaged
with the website and had
previously been engaged
with the website are actually
spending more money in-store
per month, which
is a huge benefit
to get insight into that because
as a website that doesn't
actually sell anything
what it relates
and what it connects to in-store
is actually what matters.
So finally, to summarize,
the impact that we've
seen of combining Google
Sheets and Data Studio together
has actually been just
simpler, faster reporting.
We're able to get
insights much quicker.
We're able to move in a
much more agile fashion.
We have a faster, more
efficient reporting workflow.
We've actually heard
back from Food Lion
that they're saving
about 25 hours
every month that
they were spending
creating these reports.
They've reduced
that workflow time,
so that actually helps their
internal process quite a bit.
We've moved from multiple
platforms into one.
We see this especially
with their team of social
that we have logging
into Facebook Insights,
logging into Twitter Analytics,
and being able to pull
that information down.
We've actually moved this into
Sheets and Data Studio for them
to get all that information.
We moved from multiple
reports into one.
We're no longer sending
spreadsheets around.
We're no longer having
these different formats.
We have one multi-page
report inside
of Data Studio that actually
is giving their executive team
a high level view of everything
going on in their company.
We have viewers that
can interact with data
like they couldn't before.
Previously, especially when we
talk about spreadsheet files,
you had to give the
raw dataset every time
that you worked with people.
But because of the
data governance inside
of Data Studio, we
could have viewers
of that report that
actually could get insights
from that report without needing
access to the data source
itself, which was very
powerful for their situation.
And then finally, insights
can be found faster.
At the end of the day,
if we're not actually
finding insights in our data
and taking action on them
then we're kind of just
spinning our wheels.
And so what we want to
see at the end of the day
is for users to come in,
get insights, understand
what social posts are working,
understand what coupon product
categories are actually
causing user behaviors that we
want to see in stores.
And so we're seeing that happen
with a combination of Google
Sheets and Data Studio.
So next, I'll have Andy
from Whirlpool come up
and talk about how they're
using these solutions.
ANDY LEWIS: All right.
Hi folks.
Wow, that is loud.
My name's Andy Lewis.
I'm from Whirlpool corporation.
I lead a team at Whirlpool
called the Winning Workplace.
And what that team is is it
was a purpose built team.
In fact, it was purpose built
because we were the Google Go
Live team in the beginning.
But it was purpose
built specifically
to drive the adoption and
transformation of the Google
tools at Whirlpool.
We wanted to make sure that
we were getting the most out
of what we were doing, and
collaboration was really
the most important part of this.
The reason that we went with
Google in the first place
was actually because we
wanted to drive a culture
change at Whirlpool.
Now, when I talk
about culture I'm
really not talking
about our heritage.
We've got a very
strong heritage.
We're extremely proud of
our heritage at Whirlpool.
We've been around
for 100 or so years.
Iconic brands like
KitchenAid and Maytag.
What I'm really talking
about is our behaviors,
and how are we
collaborating with folks,
and how fast are we
to decision making.
Who do we involve in the
different discussions
that we're having?
How siloed are how, and easy
is it to get to information?
And so with that,
the only tool that we
felt that we could
accomplish this with
was just G Suite and Google.
With that, we also
knew that it wasn't
going to be a quick
flip of the switch,
and it was just going to
happen, that we needed to kind
of shepherd that through.
So a number of
things that we did.
The first one was actually
we looked at our environment.
And it was our physical
space, where we were sitting.
Were we sitting next to the
folks we needed to sit to.
We have an open
office environment,
and we felt that we could
do better with that.
And so Winning Workplace started
out with our real estate team
first and foremost and actually
cleaned up that environment.
We're refreshing all
of our buildings.
We have a beautiful new
North American headquarters,
and we got people into a
physical space that actually
helped with collaboration.
On top of that, when we
looked at our virtual space,
we've got employees
all over the globe.
100,000 employees in a
number of different regions.
And how could we
help enable them
to collaborate across distances
the same way that we did
with the physical
environment and collaborating
within the buildings?
So with that, we now have G
Suite, and we put that in.
We wanted to make sure that
we were actually getting
collaboration appropriately.
So some of the
questions that we had,
and one in here at the
bottom is for today.
But some of the questions
we had was, first
of all, what is
successful collaboration?
Just because there's a number of
people that we're sharing with
and they're in the
different documents
that doesn't mean that we're
actually collaborating.
The second one is how are we
being effective as a team?
And this is my team.
Are we being effective
in the efforts
that we're doing to
try and help folks
to collaborate and to get
better at this in G Suite
adoption and transformation?
And then the third one
today is why did we
use Data Studio to take
a look at all of this
and put it all together.
So for us, collaboration, there
was a really easy indicator
that we could look
at for collaboration,
and it was in the Hangouts tool.
Hangouts for us was
a real easy one,
because it means every
time you've got somebody
using a Hangout,
you've got somebody
that's face-to-face that's not
sitting next to each other.
So that means that, yeah,
we are enabling folks
to work across
distances appropriately.
So we could even look
at this one-to-one
and say, OK, every time
we're using Hangouts,
we're getting value out of
this, and we're helping folks
to get their work done.
The things that we
looked at, if you
take a look at some
of the slides up here,
we do look at our weekly usage.
So how many Hangouts
are happening
on a day-to-day basis.
We also want to look at
not just that, but then
how many actual meetings
are being done by Hangouts.
So not just the
individual people,
but the actual individual
meetings themselves
that we know are being
conducted by Hangout.
One of the interesting
metrics that we had
was when we turned
Hangouts on in 2015
in January, after
a year, in 2016,
we were running at about
1,000 Hangouts per day.
So that's not
individual Hangouts,
but 1,000 meetings
were actually being
held over Hangout per day.
This year at that
time, we're now up
to about 3,000 meetings
per day on Hangouts.
So just exponential
take off of this.
But without being able to look
at the actual data behind it,
we would have no idea.
So the trending is good.
But the other thing that
we did was we invested
in Chromebox for meetings.
And if you don't
know what those are,
those are the Hangout rooms,
so you can install them
into a physical location,
tie them into your calendar,
and then walk in,
and with one click,
start a meeting up, and
get a Hangout going.
Those have helped with
adoption tremendously,
because now it's very easy for
people in different locations,
especially in our
manufacturing plants,
we've got those scattered
all over the globe,
so we now can connect
to those places
like we never had
been able to before.
The way that we put
this dashboard together,
and this is all in Data
Studio, is actually
we pulled an APIs out of Google.
And this is a unique solution
using both Data Studio
and Google Sheets.
So we pulled the APIs in
right into Google Sheets
so that we could take a look at
all of that raw data in Sheets.
Well, in that format,
it's not really that
easy to take a look at for us,
because there's so much of it,
and it didn't answer the
questions immediately
what we had.
So then what we did was we
pumped it all into Data Studio.
So now we've got these
really big robust dashboards,
and then we can put those
URLs out and give those
to our leadership and
they can take a look
and see how we're
performing with Hangouts.
The second one, though,
is that these Hangout
rooms that we had put in,
these Chromebox for meetings,
the neat part about
this was that we just
had a Google sheet in
there, and we manually
update that every time we add
another room to the inventory,
and then it pulls it back in.
And now we've got
a dashboard that
is coming through a couple
of different locations.
But I have one place that I
can send leadership to and say
here's how we're adopting and
yes, we are getting the most
out of our investment.
So the second
question for us was
how are we with our personal--
the Winning Workplace,
training and embedment--
and are we really helping folks
to get better at Google Tools?
So one of the things
that we do is we go out
and we have these sessions.
We call them immersion days.
And we have folks
out there, we ask
them to take three to four
hours out of their day,
and we bring departments
on all at once.
And then we work with
them to give them
some help on just what's out.
Sheets, Slides, Docs.
How to share.
How to use Drive better.
The thing is it's a pretty big
investment for those folks,
and it's an investment
for our team.
And we want to make sure that
we're actually helping them
by going through all
of this training.
Because you've all been
through training classes
that you've sat through
the training and gone,
well, there's three
hours of my life shot.
So we're hoping to avoid that.
So what we're looking at
here is a couple of things.
One is we want to,
obviously, we want
to see the Google tools,
the usage increase.
We also want to see the other
tools that we're using go away,
some of the competitor tools
and other things in this space.
So we're tracking both of those.
But the important
part of this is
that we're also
tracking the folks
and how they're feeling
about the tools.
So we have surveys that
go out before each session
and ask people so what is your
self-proficiency in Slides,
Sheets, Docs, Gmail.
And then afterwards, we
ask them the same thing
and see if we've helped
them with their proficiency.
So the way that we put
this together was we
pull all of our Google data.
We actually put
this into BigQuery.
So it's a different dataset
than the Google Sheets.
But we put this into
BigQuery and then
we also put in a bunch of
data on the other tools
that we're using as
well, and tie that all
together into a few different
datasets and BigQuery.
Then we actually put
in a hierarchy data
too, so we can actually
put in all of the people
and understand
where they roll up
in the organization
by department
and by senior leader.
And then we can take a
look at that information
and understand,
OK, this department
is doing really well.
And this department
needs some help.
So that's the data
flow on that top
to get us to the dashboards.
But on the bottom
one, what we've done
is we've used
Google Forms, and we
send the self-assessment
questionnaire out
in a Google form.
That information flows
into Google Sheets.
We take some of that data, we
put it into the Data Studio
to use for analysis.
But some of that we
leave right in Google
Sheets, and we just
constantly update it.
And then now what that
does is it gives us
a little bit of a
tie-in and a context
to, OK, we just met
with this organization.
They didn't feel
really good beforehand.
We did all the training.
We're seeing the usage spike,
and now afterwards they're
feeling great.
That's what you're hoping for.
What we actually have found out
by building this solution out
is we will go into
an organization,
say they need some help.
They're not feeling too good.
They're not very
confident in the tools.
But boy, they're using it.
So that means that the team
is out there actually using
the tool for a lot of
their day-to-day work.
But they still don't
feel competent at it.
So either we need to help them
with a little bit of training
or they're struggling.
And it's just an
analysis we never
would have gotten
to if we hadn't
put all these things together
in the tools in the way that we
did.
So with that, I believe
I hand it off to Dan.
DAN GUNDRUM: Thank you,
Andy and Jeremy as well.
So you first saw us talk to
you about Google Sheets, Data
Studio, why we think it
works well for companies.
But also a few of
our partners too.
From Analytics
Pros and Whirlpool
on how they're already
using these tools
in small and large companies
to really make an impact,
get some useful insights,
and make important business
decisions.
Basically, to just to quickly
summarize, what you've seen
is a lot of this was
really easy to get set up.
There's seamless integration
between products.
Things update easily
and efficiently.
It's live updating.
Everything's stored
in the cloud.
You saw me pull in data
from another spreadsheet.
Nick was able to take that
exact same data source
and start piping it
into Data Studio.
And then you saw the partners
do basically the same thing
with their use cases as well.
And again, I just
want to reiterate
this is all available
already in G Suite.
And as Nick was
referring to, it's
Data Studio's
completely free as well.
So looking ahead too to
hint of things coming.
Nick mentioned just yesterday
they had a big announcement.
Data Studio is basically
going across the world.
All of us are
working with people
in other countries in
different locations,
and so Data Studio is
now from 20 countries
all the way up to 180 and
probably growing, right?
You can expect
tighter integrations
between products in the future,
so look forward to that.
And several more powerful
enterprise ready features.
I think the one thing
to really take away
is that we're super
committed to the enterprise.
And we really do want to
add more powerful features
to help you perform analysis
and to make your businesses run
more efficiently
and more smoothly.
So with that, here are a
few links to check out.
If you do want more information
on where G Suite is going check
out that first link
g.co/cloudconnect.
This actually lists
a few features
in our roadmap coming up.
So things that we haven't
necessarily launched yet,
but we will be announcing
and delivering soon.
Stay tuned to also our
G Suite updates blog.
If you're not
familiar with it, that
lists the things
that have launched.
And check out our Help
Center for more information
if you want to learn more about
the connectors inside of Data
Studio and connecting to Sheets
and making sure that happens.
And of course, check out our
partners and the links there.
I'll also plug another session.
I believe it's
later in this week.
I think it's on Friday.
A whole session devoted
to our roadmaps.
So if you are interested on
that, check that out too.
It's in the schedule page.
[MUSIC PLAYING]